[Applause]
if they anchored themselves to the
mountain it'll bring the whole
helicopter down okay
what's happened
all was was bone where is your thumb now
winter and benjamin was not there
people died when they fall in a crevasse
9-1-1 what's the address of the
emergency
ice cliff glacier
two climbers two injured to ascend or
descend
what is the nature of the injuries
there's a broken leg and facial
lacerations so the broken leg they're
unable to walk yeah and is he awake yeah
he is is there any bleeding he's still
cognizant and aware so i don't think
internal bleeding no
we're on the ice cliff right above the
glacier on the north side of mount
stewart
the call comes from high altitude more
than eight thousand feet up the
notorious icecliff glacier climbing
route
two climbers report falling one thousand
feet to the foot of a steep gully
in my experience i've never seen people
fall a thousand feet down a near
vertical slope and survive
you knew they were going to be in a bad
way you know even best case scenario
they're going gonna be messed up but
just how messed up a lot of calls like
that when you hear that
it's a body recovery
it was last minute
it wasn't standard loadout i just oh i
don't have a knife and i took it off and
put it on my harness
had i not had that knife i
hate to think of the what-ifs
my concerns are slope and avalanche
dangers
i know right away this is going to be an
extremely high risk mission
rescue tech george alvarez switches on
his helmet camera as they climbed over 8
500 feet and the very limits of their
helicopters power
the huey has a
max operating ceiling of 9000 feet
you can feel the the bird not responding
as normal when you hear different sounds
the shutters it's it's an unnerving
you start scanning the snow fields and
you're not sure exactly where to look on
this
almost vertical slope
but it didn't take long to spot two
little dots in the middle of the snow
out in no man's land
rescue tech george alvarez wears the
only camera on the mission the most
pressing
danger that stood out was the slope
you don't have a
hold of your gear it's going to slide
down the mountain if you lose a handhold
you're going to slide down the mountain
and that's just one of the deadly
challenges
the victims lie in an avalanche chute
large snow deposits below them suggest
serious avalanche activity
i didn't know if the huey coming in
there that close to the slope was going
to initiate an avalanche
[Music]
it's a very loud helicopter and all that
snow and ice is above him
at any time it can just come crashing
down
when we hear voices starting to stress
in the back and agitation it's because
the tension is high
is this even possible can we do this
[Music]
alvarez and his helmet cam are going
solo
200 feet down to the slope
[Music]
assessing the snowfield that they were
on and there's cracks in it above and
below them
all that hanging ice let's go
it could go from bad to really bad i
mean catastrophic
the casualties are surrounded by danger
a rescue tech normally detaches from the
winch as soon as they touch down but
this time chief pilot potter insists
that george stay attached to the
helicopter for the entire rescue
if the mountain starts coming down on us
they're just going to rip me off the
side and try to get me out of the
avalanche and i told him i'm going to
grab the first guy i can
[Music]
but his descent starts to go wrong
george alvarez's spin develops into a
potentially deadly spiral
and that just got worse and worse
it's just a blur it's like being on a
merry-go-round but that's traveling at
50 miles an hour
it's ice it's it's concrete in some
spots
depending on how hard i hit the ground
if i enter myself the mission's over
those two are going to be staying where
they are
it was like hitting some men
i don't remember how long i
stayed there uh just collecting myself
letting everything stop spinning
he lands below the victims in case his
touchdown triggers an avalanche
once i could tell which way was up or i
started scrambling hands and knees
normally the helicopter flies away until
the rescue tech can assess the situation
not today further increasing the risk of
avalanche
as george approaches the men
he sees a trail of blood in the snow
[Music]
is there any deformity
[Music]
okay
i might have to discharge you up
you're good with that
in his fall eddie mcfarland's leg
twisted so badly that his femur snapped
in three places
getting eddie with his broken leg into a
harness is going to take time so george
decides to hoist his partner eric out
first
i'm seeing all this damage to his face
damage to his helmet he hit really
really hard to have this so i'm thinking
skull fracture i'm thinking
neck spinal injuries
i'd remember like a pretty heavy impact
on my helmet and i'm pretty sure that's
when i got knocked unconscious hit me
like right on the back of my head
and
my face was so
swollen you know my eyes were like
pretty closed
and i was like
it's not good
even if i had the opportunity to um put
him on a backboard the slope was so
severe it wouldn't have been feasible
and again
every second counted
the quicker we could get out of there
without
starting an avalanche the better
hey i'll be right back
the danger of having loose debris space
blankets
coats sleeping bags if that gets sucked
into a rotor
they'll bring the whole bird down
alvarez takes eric away from the debris
to lessen the chance of it getting
sucked up by the rotor wash
[Music]
[Music]
took off spinning around like a top on a
cable winch hanging below the helicopter
with the rotor wash and with all the
like noise
that is an insane situation
[Music]
[Music]
and i
remembered a sense of what if they
decide they can't get eddie
what if something happens and they have
to fly away without him
hey his legs are really bad
and that was like a pretty unbearable
thought
i was just petrified
[Music]
in the cascade mountains of washington
state a rescue team plucks injured
climber eric strickler from the side of
mount stewart
eric fell nearly 1 000 feet smashing his
face and helmet and sustaining neck and
back injuries
[Music]
now they must work fast to save his
climbing partner eddie mcfarland
the steep avalanche chute with a broken
leg
every second counted
the quicker we could get out of there
without starting an avalanche the better
i told the guys hey i'm gonna grab them
and
and let's go
all right
it's the same deal
because it's the terrain i can't split
it here
so hold onto it i'm going to try to be
as careful as possible but it might hurt
in the suit there's no stabilization for
his leg
said you have no idea of how much you
know this is gonna hurt here
you're gonna have to lift your butt up a
little
okay
all right now
all right
and then i see several sections of rope
that are now attached to eddy
so i automatically think that they
anchored themselves to the mountain this
is the absolute worst case scenario
he fears the helicopter is tied to the
mountain if the helicopter starts
getting forward momentum and we're
hardpointed in it'll bring the whole
helicopter down
i have to get that rope cut otherwise
everybody might die
as soon as that last rope went through
and cut it it was just just a huge huge
relief
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that was definitely the most painful
thing i've experienced
but i was
ecstatic
getting rescued
you know we're actually going to survive
this
since
this incident our standard kit now is a
large fixed blade knife for row cutting
for survival for you name it so i want
contribution to the unit
and all the rescues i've flown in the
last 15 years it's the highest waste
i've done
and it's probably the nastiest slope
i've done
it was
definitely up there as
my top one
[Music]
i think they're some of the most
admirable
people that have ever
come into my life
just incredibly
incredibly humbling
it just makes me very grateful to be
alive still
is
it's the first time we climb stroller
and we
enjoy to
to go to the top because it is very
beautiful place
roland spielhorn his son benjamin wife
isabelle and their friend francis
reached the summit of the mighty
stalhorn peak
which rises over 13
hundred feet in the swiss alps
we're happy because we've done it
so we we we do that each time yeah
the four adventurers now face the
dangerous ski down through hazardous
backcountry
today three of the four film their
journey
[Music]
we want to keep an eye on the person who
is going first
in fact
he looks this on live study
[Music]
a one by one
we decent
[Music]
the group agrees on a course and sets
off benjamin going last
[Music]
as the ground opens up beneath benjamin
clings to the side of a crevasse a deep
crack in a glacier
and things are about to get even worse
[Music]
let's go
high in the swiss alps a crevasse opens
with skier benjamin spillhorn
and he clings to the sides for dear life
[Music]
he's fallen 30 feet but inches from his
head the crevasse plunges down so far
he can't see the
bottom further down the steep ski slope
his parents have no idea what's happened
we
go down about 200 meters
and
we returned
and beijing was not there
[Music]
where is benjamin
[Music]
maybe he has fallen down
uh so wait
it's a really
bad feeling we don't want to believe
it's an accident
[Music]
benjamin can't risk climbing out for
fear he'll slip even further into the
abyss or trigger the sides to collapse
in on him
down the slope his parents are getting
frantic
we were just asking each person we saw
at the end of the slope have you seen
somebody have you seen bajamar and
people say no no
there is only one possible conclusion
their son has fallen into a crevasse
[Music]
a lot of people died and they fall in a
crevasse
it is alive dead
benjamin's now been lying for 15 minutes
on a snow bridge across the middle of
the crevasse
usually they'd collapse under the weight
of an adult
but this one may have saved his life
he breaks out his pack of climbing tools
securing himself to the crevasse wall
with an ice screw in case the snow
bridge collapses
but he still has no way of getting out
francis
isabel
begin to climb to bajamar
to go to him we need around 20 minutes
[Music]
i have to go there faster
[Music]
when i was climbing i was just thinking
climb climb and that's all
after 17 minutes in the crevasse
benjamin hears a voice but not one he
recognizes
[Music]
a passing mountain guide stumbles across
the crevasse
[Music]
when i arrive at the at the top i saw
the mountain guide and it was on on the
snow on the edge of the crevasse
if the mouth of the crevasse gives way
the snow could collapse on benjamin
foreign
foreign
i remember just waiting waiting waiting
he has to climb to get out this hall
but at this moment for me
it was death danger
high in the swiss alps skier benjamin
spillhorn faces a grueling 30-foot rope
climb out of a crevasse
if he slips and the ice crew supporting
his rope breaks free
he could fall to his death
okay
benjamin's rescuers can't risk pulling
them up in case they collapse the mouth
of the crevasse
he must make his own way out
with every swing of the ice axe benjamin
risks collapsing the walls of the
crevasse
one in 11 people who fall into a
crevasse die from snow burial
[Applause]
foreign
is
foreign
[Music]
did you see it
i'm touching
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let me see here
i saw benjamin coming out of the grass
that was i remember this mom the moment
it was like your
it's a good
it was good to see him
oh yeah just i was very afraid
i was very
[Music]
i said
all is okay and he said yes oh he's okay
and he go in the helicopter
i can't speak to him
i can't take in my arm and kiss him
when i fell
i was sure
that i was killing myself
i did not expect to land on snow
actually
[Music]
and sometimes you
the difference between
to live or to die
is really
pretty small
two weeks later
benjamin returns to the alps
and resume skiing in the stunning
glacial backcountry
[Music]
for you
[Music]
someone's had a serious hand injury that
needs to be retrieved
the saint john northland helicopter
rescue team gets the emergency call from
a fishing vessel still out at sea
what worries them is how little they
know
it's pretty limited information a cray
fisherman and something about his hand
getting caught on the winch and
we didn't know whether it would just
involve fingers or whether he's ripped
his hand off
the priority is to get this patient to a
specialist surgeon
is there a major bleed that can't be
controlled
and if a bleed can't be controlled
that person
can can die from it
the crew face a series of daunting
challenges just to reach the boat
from their base and fungi it's the 300
mile round trip to three kings island
well out of their helicopter's fuel
range there are no refueling stops for
us up that far the only option was to
carry our own extra fuel
we were going to have to refuel
somewhere along the way but it adds
extra time time we didn't have
the rescuers need to winch the injured
fisherman off the boat and get him to a
hospital as soon as possible
there's a couple of elements that are
playing against this one is that it'll
be night so the pilots will
need to find
some reference hopefully with the
island it's also predicted that the seas
might be quite large
and a quite gusty wind
there was a storm coming in from the
west arriving about the same time as we
were going to be there
we're going to be
winching in the dark and that really
puts the pressure on
in such stormy conditions the winch line
has to be secured to the boat before
they can risk sending sam down
this means the helicopter will be
attached to the fishing vessel for the
entire winch
one of the riskiest maneuvers in air
rescue
if you get the winch cable tan ground on
the boat that can pull the aircraft into
the seat
if there's a emergency where we need to
cut the cable
um
i can either activate the cable cutter
on the back yeah or i will call the top
it's hot
as we headed north it got darker and
darker
being that it's at night in stormy
conditions and involving a boat they all
come together for the perfect storm
off the north coast of new zealand a
helicopter rescue team combs the black
seas for a boat
they've received reports that a wounded
fisherman may be bleeding out on the
vessel which is close to the uninhabited
three kings island
you know the highest point on this uh
this island three or four hundred feet
okay i'm just starting to see it now and
the light is shining up behind it
it's coming into view on the right
we descended out of cloud and picked up
the island
the wind was getting strong and it had
the potential to make it rough and quite
a difficult lynch
coming down real slow towards the boat
we saw the light of the boat and that
was the first light we'd seen probably
for the last 20 or 30 minutes it was in
such a remote area
mark has to get rescue tech sam onto the
boat to extract the injured fisherman
they have agreed a plan to lower a winch
line onto the deck which a member of the
boat crew will tie to the vessel
but if the boat pulls on the hoist line
it can drag the chopper into the sea
a really really dark night really windy
situation
a boat that's moving up and down and
sideways and the aircraft that's getting
buffeted from all different directions
it was right up there sort of knocking
on 10 out of 10.
the winch line has been secured to the
boat
mark must now control the slack of the
line to get rescue tech sand down safely
it gets the pulse racing
adrenaline's rushing through your veins
this is a the most delicate part of the
operation
you're wondering is sam going to land up
in the water
are they going to hit the side of the
vessel
hi everybody
sam's my name what was your name
terry what's happened terry um i'd love
to come off come on and where is your
thumb now
everything's still in the club
okay i think we just put you in here i
can jump to the helicopter
and then get you away once you're in the
helicopter we can have a look at it give
you something for pain
okay you'll need to take your hat off
can we get a life jacket
that
initial five to ten minutes of that real
hardcore pain you had to soak up that
had gone
and uh there was more adrenaline pumping
you know
hey terry
how are you feeling anyway
oh good excellent and you've got a nice
strong pulse here which sounds good too
eh and your color's good i was asking
them questions like hey man was he no
yeah
blood
gets oh because it's been ripped off not
cut off
you know a clean cut all it was was um
bone
bone and gristle let's get that off
quickly
sam knows they've got to move fast
his pilot is struggling to maintain a
hover in the driving winds and rain
weather was deteriorating
we were in quite heavy rain
keeping orientated is the most difficult
thing you can imagine you don't know
where uppers and down is it's a
very delicate situation and you're
relying on all your senses
the helicopter is running low on fuel
[Music]
they can't afford to make a single
mistake
getting that tension on the cable is
really tricky
if the cable is too tight would risk
pulling them into the water
if it's too loose then that could tangle
around anything on the boat and could
could pull the aircraft into the sea
there's a lot of pressure to get it
right
there our lives at risk
in high winds off the coast of new
zealand a helicopter rescue team is
about to winch a seriously injured
fisherman and one of their own rescue
crew from a storm-lashed boat
you know i looked at him he banged his
light and we just went
and i was like whoa
yeah that freaked me out
[Music]
yep
the eclipse there peter to the left
[Applause]
feels that his thumb's been pulled off
needs to be there within six hours for a
surgeon to
to have any chance of putting that back
on
the clock's ticking
it's already been three hours since the
accident the pilot has to refuel before
they can get terry to surgery
if the worsening storm grounds them
there'll be no hope of saving his thumb
exactly
[Applause]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
turned around and looked at it craig
skipper and i went my thumb's gone broke
craig says oh you you
your fishing crew's over
you know i'm lying on my back
in the wheelhouse
you know um sucking up at the
and when he said that
i
started getting tears out of my eyes
to have any chance of saving his thumb
medic mark must ensure that the wound is
clean and he doesn't go into shock
he could have had circulation issues
infection issues which may have in fact
resulted in more than him just losing
his thumb are you able to just move your
hand this way
like that's perfect
oh yeah there you go i can see that
through there yep so that's just above
the uh
as we started cutting a glove off we
soon realised that
the extent of damage to his thumb was
immense
there was nothing much holding it on
and there's nothing that we could do to
to improve that situation
the helicopter manages to refuel and get
carried to the hospital with a traumatic
amputation like this every second counts
if we weren't
able to winch him off that
boat in time
it would have been a 10 or 12 hour to
get back to was caught and then to
hospital after that
depending on the infection and being
able to get on top of that there's
potential to lose life as well
it's too late too late to fall back on
i'll see you it was over
i decided that i didn't want to find
other work
well just wasn't me
and so
i decided to go back fishing i went see
craig
and he says
come and do a trip wait oh yeah okay
he's pretty robust terry so
he's just persevered with it and he's
working back on the boat now so he's
back fishing
good to hear that he's still out in the
fishing industry doing his thing
although he's lost his thumb it could
have been a lot lot worse
[Music]
it was the whole thumb it was down here
i wouldn't be doing the same thing i
wouldn't be able to tie knots
so half of it you see i can i can use
that
i'm happy that i've only lost half a
thumb
in
[Music]
you